on season four of 90 day fiancé
before the 90 days we met the first gay
couple in the history of the franchise
Stephanie and Eric it's my first ever
morning waking up next to my girlfriend
Erica you're like such a nice thing to
wake up to our connection is unlike
anything I've ever felt before
and when we finally kissed last night it
was really nice she's a really good
kisser I know I was rooting for them but
since Stephanie arrived in Australia
things have not gone quite as play like
it's crazy I have to take this
medication with me everywhere I go
because this is kind of what keeps me
alive it's concerning
besides Stephanie not revealing the full
extent of her health issues to Erica the
lack of intimacy has weighed on the
relationship you know telling me that
you want to have this next big
relationship and whatever and then on
the other hand you're essentially
telling me like you're not ready to be
intimate and that's really confusing
however the biggest issues within the
relationship seem to stem from
Stephanie's jealousy and insecurities
this has caused some major blowout
fights between the two take a look at
this one which was about Erica using a
dating app for her business
so like this date is actually over
no I well you get just like Susie oh
let's go
I'm not your provide god yeah she's
gonna have to learn to trust me
otherwise this relationship is not gonna
work during a visit to Erica's hometown
while Stephanie was in the bathroom
Erica revealed to a friend that things
were not going well instead for like
notes why would I expect it that's some
jealousy things going on yeah and it's
like I'm trying to get to a point of
trust with her at the same time we're
not being intimate we're not really
kissing holding hands
nothing mm-hmm and things really came to
a head later that night when they got
back to their apartment you don't want
to do anything you don't want to you're
saying I like meeting new people is hard
you're saying that me planning dates is
hard literally everything is too much
like why did you even go Mia why like
why bother stuff if you can't be
affectionate if you don't want to meet
my friends really sorry perhaps the
biggest fight between the couple
happened when they went to a house party
with Erica's friends and Erica's past
sexual relationships came up I'm here
for three weeks I'm trying to figure
this whole thing out cuz this is weird
to me and you're getting upset at me yes
what I'm trying to get comfortable I'm
trying to figure this all out okay
tomorrow
don't say that you haven't yelled at me
because you are at Yahoo when I'm trying
to talk to you like an adult after
taking some time apart the two got
together to discuss what's next for
their relationship I'm just exhausted
from having the same like conversation
over and over again
last night was embarrassing I love her
so much and I do want to make things
work so I'm just gonna try and open up
to her and trust her more because I know
that's really important to Erica coming
up the couple have another milestone in
their relationship Erica is going to
come out to her parents are you enjoying
this er yeah we've had a really good
time weighs one word what about you you
have a ball coming out to my parents it
is really scary because I'm not really
sure how they're gonna react I'm poor
NASA's away because whoo it has been a
roller coaster with stuffing in Erica so
what do you think of their relationship
which 90 day fiancé
before the 90 days couple do you think
we'll last have you ever fallen in love
with somebody in another country let me
know in the comments below
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos